- I wanted to mention something
'cause I used a GIF of you.
Because I love you, and it's funny.
So, I was having the worst day ever.
Literally, my dryer broke,
my clothes ended up,
we have no clothesline,
so I just had to hang them
on the back porch area.
And they flew off into the forest,
and I had to go find all of them.
And, anyway, it was a really rough day.
And then, I got back in
and I had all these
texts, and they were like,
Man, so now there's Murder Hornets.
And I was like, "Wait, what?"
And I started looking up
what the hell a Murder Hornet was.
And then I, anyway, I used
your GIF that was like, "Sure."
Like, of course this
is happening, why not?
- Yeah.
- Have you heard of Murder Hornets?
- No, I mean, I was, this weekend,
reading a newspaper article about it.
And again, it was just
one of those things,
we did a thing on our show
called, Not Now, Murder Hornets,
which is, we don't have the bandwidth
to be worried about you at this moment.
- (laughs loudly)
- If you were looking to make
a splash, Murder Hornets,
you picked the wrong time, I think.
You need to do it before,
or after, a pandemic,
in the middle of it.
I think there are people
who are, at this point,
would be terrified about Murder
Hornets at any other time
that are now like, "Great,
whatever. Bring it on.
Let's just have it all at once."
- I'm honestly, and this happened
to me the other day, too.
There was an earthquake here,
and I didn't know earthquakes
happened in Montana.
And I was just like, when
are the locusts coming?
- Yeah.
- Everything is just going to crap.
I don't know what's happening.
And it's not, that was a bad day.
But, anyway, I just thought it was funny.
'Cause they're called
Murder Hornets, apparently,
because they decapitate honey bees.
They just take their head off.
Which I was like, of course we would have
something called a
Murder Hornet right now.